[Musik]
und jetzt das heute
journal auf dem Weg in die Freiheit nach
7 Wochen wurden die ersten Geiseln
[Musik]
übergeben guten Abend zum heute journal
sie sind frei doch wie frei und sicher
sie sich jemals wieder fühlen werden
steht dahin unter den Verschleppten sind
Kinder die am 7 Oktober zusahen wie ihre
Eltern massakriert wurden bevor die
Täter sie mitnahmen und niemand weiß was
den Geiseln während ihrer Gefangenschaft
dann noch alles angetan wurde die jetzt
freigelassenen werden zunächst von
Psychologen und Ärzten betreut und mit
ihren Angehörigen zusammengebracht viele
werden vielleicht noch gar nicht wissen
wer aus ihren Familien oder ihrem kibutz
überhaupt noch lebt Dominik Lessmeister
berichtet aus Tel Aviv Jubel und Freude
am Abend in Israel die freigelassenen
Geiseln werden zu einer Luftwaffen Basis
im Süden des Landes Gefahren zuvor haben
Mitarbeiter des Roten Kreuzes 13
Israelis Z Thailänder und ein
philippinischer Staatsbürger die die
Hamas freigelassen hat erst über Ägypten
dann nach Israel gebracht unter den
Israelis vier deutsche doppelstatler
befreit sind die Familien von Johnny
Ascher seine Frau Doron und die beiden
Töchter sowie margalet Berta Moses ich
bin unendlich erleichtert dass soeben 24
Geiseln aus Gaza freigekommen sind
darunter vier deutsche dass ein Vater
nach 49 Tagen der Hölle des
unglaublichen Bangens endlich seine zwei
kleinen Töchter seine Ehefrau wieder
sicher in die Arme schließen
kann Erleichterung und Freude bei den
Angehörigen und Unterstützern der
Geiseln in Tel Aviv die gerbanze Woche
über haben sich die Menschen hier
versammelt Druck auf die Regierung
gemacht in der geiselfrage eine
Vereinbarung zu finden 13 aus über 200
Geisel ist doch ein Anfang es sind zwar
nicht viele aber wir haben ein gutes
Gefühl es ist traurig dass immer noch
welche dort sind es tut ein bisschen weh
für die Menschen aber wir hoffen
weiter israels Ministerpräsident
netanyaho verfolgte mit den Mitgliedern
seines Kabinetts die Übergabe er
verspricht den Angehörigen ich betone
gegenüber Ihnen den Familien und
gegenüber den Bürgern Israels dass wir
uns für die Rückkehr aller unserer
Geiseln einsetzen das ist eines der
Kriegsziele und wir sind entschlossen
alle Kriegsziele zu erreichen im
Gegenzug ließ Israel anschließend 39
Palästinenser aus Gefängnissen frei 24
Frauen und 15 Jugendliche in ramala im
westjordan Land Freude auf den Straßen
heute Abend über die von Israel
freigelassenen
Häftlingen für tausende Flüchtlinge im
Gazastreifen war die Feuerpause die
erste Gelegenheit seit krisbeginn um
ungefährdet nach Freunden und Verwandten
zu suchen sich zu vergewissern was aus
ihren Häusern geworden
ist ich muss zu unserem Haus das liegt
östlich von ranunis an der israelischen
Grenze so etwas wie diesen Krieg hatten
wir noch nie in unserer Geschichte als
Teil der Vereinbarung kommen
Hilfslieferung in den gaserstreifen
Lebensmittel medizinische Güter und
Treibstoff bereits seit dem Morgen in
den kommenden vier Tagen sind 200
Lastwagen täglich vereinbart neben der
Freude für die freigelassenen hoffen sie
für morgen auf weitere Geiseln die
zurück nach Hause
kommen dann schalten wir noch zu unserem
Korrespondenten Michael beberunge
Michael die die Feuerpause die scheint
ja zu halten also es fliegen derzeit
keine Raketen weder von der einen noch
von der anderen
Seite ja nach 7 Wochen heftigster kämpte
Kämpfe konnte man sich eigentlich kaum
vorstellen dass es dann von einem auf
dem anderen Moment ruhig bleiben würden
die Waffen schweigen noch in der Nacht
haben die Israelis versucht mit massiven
artillerieangriffen noch mal ihre Ziele
voranzutreiben und was das ist auch
interessant da hat heute gar keiner mehr
dran gedacht auch im Norden blieb es
ruhig obwohl der Norden die Front mit
der hbolla überhaupt nicht in diesen
waffenstillstandsdeal einbezogen war was
man sehen muss ist wie sich das
entwickelt was sich heute auch schon
abgezeichnet hat dass viele
Palästinenser wieder in den Norden
zurückdrängen die Israelis haben mit
Flugblättern angesagt dass bitte die
Palästinenser nicht zurückgehen sollen
und haben auch Truppen vorgehalten um
notfalls größere Ansammlung von Menschen
zu zerstreuen aber im Verlauf der Tage
wird es vielleicht noch viel mehr
Menschen attraktiv erscheinen doch mal
wieder zurückzukehren um zu gucken was
mit dem eigenen Hab und Gut passiert ist
und da könnte sich doch noch ein
größeres Konfliktpotenzial draus ergeben
ja man man fragt sich ja eh wie man sich
das in Gaza konkret vorzustellen hat
also die Isra ischen Truppen bleiben da
im Norden schießen aber
nicht im Moment jedenfalls nicht ich
würde sagen sie stellen sich auch neu
auf die Hamas wird sich sicherlich
reorganisieren aber auch die Israelis
werden ihre Truppen genauer aufstellen
werden schauen was sie bisher erreicht
haben und eines ist klar daran lässt
zumindest hier die politische Führung
kein Zweifel sobald die Waffenruhe
beendet ist soll es mit den kämpfen
weitergehen denn eins ist klar die Hamas
kann nur vollständig zerschlagen werden
wenn man denn tatsächlich auch bereit
ist in den Süden einzumarschieren mit
neuen Katastrophen dort was bedeutet
diese FE Feuerpause denn jetzt für die
notleidende Bevölkerung in Gasa kommt
bei den Menschen dort denn jetzt mehr
Hilfe
an ja glücklicherweise erstmal viel
Gutes heute sind etwa 140 LKW mit
Hilfslieferung durchgekommen und
Treibstoff demnächst sollen es täglich
bis zu 200 werden auch das durfte sich
normalisieren mit einer längeren Folge
von Tagen wo der Waffenstillstand hält
die Frage ist ja ob der möglicherweise
noch über die vier Tage jetzt hinaush
hält aber auch jetzt hat sich die
humanitäre Hilfe stabilisiert aber auch
da stellt sich die Frage wie geht es
danach weiter wo sollen die Menschen hin
im Süden der Norden ist ja in den Süden
gegangen wenn denn die Kämpfe wieder
anfangen danke schön Michael erstmal
soweit aus Tel
Aviv und dann gehen wir nach Deutschland
in der deutschen Haushaltskrise gibt es
neue Wendungen zum einen scheint man im
Kanzleramt zu dem Schluss gekommen zu
sein dass sich die Sache zumindest nicht
ausschweigen lässt der Kanzler sprach
also heute und kündigte weitere
Wortmeldungen in Form einer
Regierungserklärung an sein
Finanzminister lindner war zuletzt auch
nicht sehr redselig gab heute aber einen
Hörfunk interterview in dem er
ankündigte dass die Strom und
gaspreisbremsen bereits mit dem
Jahresende auslaufen werden und nicht
erst wie geplant im März Frank Buchwald
berichtet aus
Berlin Christian Lindner hatte heute
einen seiner erfreulicheren Termine der
Finanzminister stellt eine
weihnachtsmünze vor Motiv ein
erzgebirgischer Schwippbogen Symbol für
Licht in tiefer Finsternis Vau e Worte
für den Künstler der das Motiv ersonnen
hat und eine launige
Rede deshalb freue ich mich so sehr dass
ich mich heute mal mit einer Silbermünze
beschäftigen muss bevor es dann später
wieder um das Geld geht das uns fehlt
das Geld das fehlt dafür lässt Lindner
heute einen der profiliertesten Köpfe in
seinem Hause Rollen er versetzt Werner
Gatzer den langjährigen
haushaltsstaatssekretär in den
einstweiligen Ruhestand Gatzer gilt als
Architekt der beanstand
etonstruktionen die Strom und
gaspreisbremsen das kündigt der Minister
später auch noch an laufen Ende des
Jahres aus D Monate früher als geplant
das Geld stamme aus dem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond und der
müsse zum 31 Dezember geschlossen werden
der Kanzler will beruhigen per
Videobotschaft Hilfen wie für Corona und
das Aral Strom oder gaspreisbremse all
das sei auch weiterhin möglich damit in
diesem Jahr die Hilfen gesichert sind
werden wir den Bundestag für das
laufende Jahr vorschlagen die für solche
Fälle im Grundgesetz ermöglichte
Ausnahme von der Schuldenbremse erneut
zu beschließen den Haushalt für das
nächste Jahr werden wir im Lichte des
Urteils genau überarbeiten zügig aber
mit der gebotenen sorgfaht währenddessen
nimmt die Diskussion über die
Schuldenbremse Fahrt auf heute auch im
Bundesrat ungebremste Schulden machen
gehe nicht sagen viele Länderchefs aber
am Ende gilt der Grundsatz die
Schuldenbremse darf keine Zukunfts und
keine bremse sein und das finde ich ist
schon ein Punkt über den man nachdenken
muss und auch ein Parlament sich die
Frage stellen muss muss man die
Schuldenbremse möglicherweise
umgestalten ähnlich hatte sich gestern
schon Kai Wegner von der CDU geäußert
der Regierende Bürgermeister von Berlin
heute ziehen die Kollegen aus Sachsen
und SachsenAnhalt nach man sollte die
Ausgestaltung genau dieser
Schuldenbremse im Sinne der
Prioritätensetzung so diskutieren dass
wir zu verfassungskonform Haushalten
kommen und trotzdem uns nicht selber
strangulieren nur NRW Ministerpräsident
wüst widerspricht noch die
Schuldenbremse ist ein schutzwahl gegen
die Übergriffigkeit der gegenwärtigen
Regierung in das port-eme künftiger
Regierung und das Prinzip ist gut und
richtig wenn ich einmal reich wä
originelle Musikauswahl heute aber
klingt sie beinah sarkastisch für einen
Finanzminister dem wirklich jeder
Groschen fehlt
[Musik]
und was denken die Bundesbürger über
Schuldenbremse und Haushaltskrise das
hat die Forschungsgruppe Wahlen fürs
aktuelle ZDF Politbarometer gefragt und
das gibt's nachher direkt im Anschluss
ans heute journal und natürlich auch
jetzt schon online auf ZDF heute der
Bundesrat hat sich heute nicht nur mit
der Haushaltskrise befasst es gab noch
weitere Themen und Entscheidungen Heinz
unter anderem zum geplanten staatlichen
onlineatlass für Krankenhäuser der
Bundesrat hat dem Gesetzesvorhaben von
Gesundheitsminister lautebach nicht
zugestimmt und schickt es in den
Vermittlungsausschuss denn in seiner
jetzigen Form werde die angestrebte
Transparenz und Orientierungshilfe für
die Patienten nicht erreicht so die
Kritik gescheitert sind im Bundesrat
vorerst neugelungen zum
Straßenverkehrsrecht die Städten und
Gemeinden mehr Spielraum geben sollten
beispielsweise für das Einrichten von
Busspuren und Tempo 30 Zonen dabei
sollten künftig auch Ziele etwa des
Klima und Umweltschutzes seine größere
Rolle spielen auch hier könnte im
Vermittlungsausschuss weiter beraten
werden die Grünen haben ihre
Parteivorsitzenden Ricarda lang und Omid
nuripur im Amt bestätigt auf dem
Parteitag in Karlsruhe mit rund 800
Delegierten wurde das führungsduro für
eine weitere zweijährige Amtszeit
gewählt auch der Europawahlkampf wird
auf dem Partei vorbereitet die
eu-plamentarierin ter reintke wird als
Spitzenkandidatin der Grünen
antreten Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat
sechs amtierende und einen ehemaligen
Ministerpräsidenten mit dem
Bundesverdienstkreuz ausgezeichnet er
würdigte damit deren langjährigen und
engagierten Dienst für die Demokratie
wie er bei der Verleihung sagte die
Auszeichnungen gingen an Dreier winfri
kretchmann haselof Bodo ramelo und Horst
Seehofer die Gewerkschaft deutscher
Lokomotivführer GDL hat die
Tarifverhandlungen mit der Deutschen
Bahn für gescheitert erklärt gdlchef
weselski kündigte an man werde den
Arbeitgeber weiter unter Druck setzen
einen Zeitpunkt für neue Warnstreiks
nannte er nicht ein zentraler
Streitpunkt ist offenbar eine
Arbeitszeitreduzierung für
Schichtarbeiter in den Niederlanden sind
die Parteien nach der Parlamentswahl nun
bei der Frage nach
Koalitionsmöglichkeiten die bisher
regierende rechtsliberale Partei VVD
erklärte sie werde nach den großen
Verlusten bei der Wahl nicht an einer
neuen Regierung teilnehmen der
Wahlsieger der Rechtspopulist Wilders
zeigte sich darüber enttäuscht er müsste
eine mehrheitsfähige Koalition finden um
Regierungschef zu
werden wir kommen noch mal zurück auf
den nostkonflikt und was die
Geschehnisse des 7 oktober in anderen
westlichen Ländern auslösten bzw
sichtbar machten viele Juden in Europa
und Nordamerika erlebten infolg dessen
einen zweiten Schock weniger weil in
berlin-neuköln z.B Sympathisanten der
heramas freudig Süßigkeiten verteilten
das war nicht so überraschend weitaus
schockierender war dass an der
amerikanischen Eliteuniversität harard
noch am 7 Oktober am Tag des Terrors ein
von dutzenden Studenten ganisation
unterschriebener Brief veröffentlicht
wurde in dem es mitleidslos hieß an den
Massakern sein die Israelis selbstschuld
und die Universitätsleitung dazu lange
schwieg das war der Auftakt und es blieb
nicht beim Briefe schreiben wie der
nostkonflikt in den akademischen milies
Gräben aufreist längst auch in
Deutschland das berichtet David
GEP jüdische Studierende bedrängt
bedroht auf dem Kamp hier in harard
nordamerikanische Unis im
Ausnahmezustand Aufruf zur Intifada an
elit schmieden wie
princon eine Stimmung die nach
Deutschland schwabt Freie Universität
Berlin dem Anfang des Monats Taktgeber
ein marxistischer
Lehramtsstudent klarer Aufruf zum
Judenmord das ist wie wenn man tötet
Juden ruft in bedeutet genau das was wir
von der Hamas gesehen haben ja wir sehen
sozusagen eine Allianz oder ein Pakt aus
linken linksmarxistisch sozialistisch
kommunistischen Gruppen die dann mit
muslimischen Gruppen und teils
islamistischen Gruppen zusammen stehen
der gemeinsame Nenner ist ihr
Antisemitismus nur einige Beispiele die
Toilette in der Mensa der FU die
Eingangshalle einer kunstuni Israel Hass
wird auf Flyer gedruckt an Hochschulen
verteilt oder Studierende über
versteckte Boxen in einer Bibliothek
beschalt Israel begehe ein
Genozid die Sicherheitslage für jüdische
Studierende an Universitäten ist gerade
wahnsinnig brenzlich bilden teilweise
sogar Laufgruppen weil sie Angst haben
alleine in die Mensa zu gehen weil sie
Angst haben alleine in die Bibliothek zu
gehen deswegen gilt es jetzt den anfäng
auch wirklich ein Einhalt zu gebieten es
gilt jetzt dass der Rechtsstaat sofort
durchgreift eine Straftat auf dem Kampus
oder auf der Straße ist eine Straftat
Antisemitismus ist eine
die deutsche Politik an der Seite
Israels aber nicht jede Israel Kritik
sei gleich Antisemitismus kritisieren
proalästinensische Studierende Demus an
mehreren Berliner Unis vergangene Woche
weil die Regierung in
deutschlandingeschränkt hinter Israel
steht und ich glaube das geht einfach
nicht wenn nicht nur Synagogen
beschmiert werden sondern Moscheen
beschmiert werden aber davon nichts
erzählt werden soll wir uns sich wir
finden schon lange nicht mehr sicher ein
wiederkehrendes Muster hier Empathie
fordern gleichzeitig aber gegen Israel
hetzen Terror verhmlosen Hamas ist eine
Widerstandsorganisation jeder von uns
sollte sich gegen ein genoit aussprechen
den anitstat begt für Mitgefühl für die
andere Seite ist mit unter genauso wenig
Platz wie für einen jüdischen Staat
neben Palästina auf dem Jutebeutel
Israel sehen viele Links progressiver
als weißen Kolonialstaat pauschal als
Täter ein Täter dem die deutsche Politik
alles durchgehen lasse weil sie sich
wegen des Holocausts schuldig fühle ihre
Forderung
ger befreit Palästina von deutscher
Schuld li Salomon der seit Jahren
Antisemitismus jeglicher Färbung
dokumentiert kennt dieses
schuldkultnarrativ eigentlich von
anderen es eine
voninkre nicht nur Herr Höke viele
Rechtsextreme werden das die stolz auf
diese plak Universitäten wollen ein Ort
der Bildung der Toleranz sein jüdische
Studierende sind sie derzeit eher ein
Ort der
Angst Menschen die aus der Ukraine nach
Deutschland geflüchtet sind können hier
weiterhin bleiben ohne einen Antrag auf
Verlängerung ihrer Aufenthaltserlaubnis
stellen zu müssen die Bundesregierung
hat die entsprechende Regelung bis März
verlängert das ist für die hier lebenden
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer zwar eine
Nachricht die sie erleichtern wird aber
es zeigt natürlich dass auch die Bundes
Regierung nicht damit rechnet dass
dieser Krieg bald vorbei sein wird die
Ukrainer gehen in den zweiten
Kriegswinter mit allem was das bedeutet
Heizungs und Stromausfälle und ständige
Bombardierungen unser Reporter Tim
Krüger ist in Cherson unterwegs dort
fliegt sozusagen die Südfront bei den
Kämpfen an den Ufern des Fluss Nepo geht
es letztlich auch im Schwarze Meer und
die
Krim Abschiedsschmerz bevor sie die die
Stadt mit einer Hilfsorganisation
verlassen Menschen lassen Angehörige
zurück auch lut Miller Christi lever hat
viel durchgemacht sie hatte chon schon
einmal den Rücken gekehrt kam zurück
wollte durchhalten aber jetzt ist die
Angst vor den täglichen Angriffen zu
groß
geworden es ist sehr schwer aber es
bleibt mir nichts anderes
übrig ich habe so sehr darauf gehofft
dass der Krieg früher zu Ende
ist aber es geht immer weiter
es sind Angriffe wie dieser die die
Menschen terrorisieren in der Nacht ist
ein Geschoss vor dem Laden von oex Hain
eingeschlagen er aber räumt schon wieder
auf hat am Morgen bereits die ersten
Kunden
bedient ich muss das hier wieder
aufbauen denn das Geschäft hat
funktioniert und die Leute in der
Umgebung mit einfachen Lebensmitteln
versorgt wie Brot und
Milch dies die in rasson bleiben stemmen
sich gegen den permanenten Beschuss und
den drohenden Winter in einem Lager
organisiert Natalia Huma als Freiwillige
die Verteilung von Spenden Ron bereitet
sich auf den Winter
vor dieses Paket ist gut es gibt eine
Taschenlampe eine Akkulampe eine
Powerbank und eine Panne einen Gasherd
um Essen warm zu
machen
hunderte Haushalte brauchen außerdem
solche Gasheizstrahler für den Fall dass
Russland wieder verstärkt elektrizitäts
und Heizkraftwerke
angreift wir haben einenwinter
überstanden und schaffen auch diesen
natürlich haben wir Angst es gibt keine
Menschen ohne
Angst die Menschen in Chan hoffen
derzeit vor allem auf militärische
Erfolge der ukrainischen Armee auf dem
linken dem russisch besetzten Ufer des
tpro sie hoffen dass es dadurch R wird
und dass die geflüchteten Menschen bald
wieder zurückkehren
können das Ziel ist das linke Ufer zu
befreien wir wollen die Anzahl der
Angriffe
reduzieren die Russen sollen etwa 30 km
weit vertrieben werden damit sie das
rechte Ufer nicht mehr
erreichten noch aber ist das die
Realität als wir her verlassen schlagen
Raketen in einem Vorort ein später
erfahren wir dass drei Menschen ums
Leben komm sein sollen wegen dieser
Angriffe will lut Miller kostileva raus
das Überleben in chern gleiche einer
Lotterie sagt sie nun möchte sie zu
einer bekannten weit weg von der Front
Arbeit finden und irgendwie durch den
Winter
kommen und jetzt geht's bei dem noch mal
weiter Heinz mit Wirtschaft in den USA
ist der Black Friday der Freitag
zwischen dem Thanksgiving Donnerstag und
dem folgenden Wochenende ein besonders
wichtiger Tag für den Einzel Handel und
in Deutschland ser mein wie läuft hier
das Black Friday Geschäft also in den
vergangenen Jahren konnte der Umsatz an
Black Friday und darauffolgenden Cyber
Monday teilweise im Einzelhandel um rund
20% gesteigert werden doch 2023 dürfte
dieser schulaut Handelsverband HDE wohl
geringer ausfallen deshalb wird dieses
Mal wegen der hohen Inflation nur von
einem Umsatzplus von 3% ausgegangen in
der Flaute locken die Händler mit satten
Rabatten besonders hoch sind sie im
Einzelhandel doch die Preisnachlässe die
im Internet online gegeben werden
zwingen auch diesen stationären
Einzelhandel bei der Preisschlacht
mitzumachen das schmälert aber wiederum
die Marge und schadet so dem wichtigen
Weihnachtsgeschäft den Black Friday
lässt sich auch werdi nicht entgehen vor
dem Hintergrund stockender
Tarifverhandlungen haben tausende
Mitarbeiter im groß und Einzelhandel in
mehreren Bundesländern heute gestreikt
die Schlangen an den Kassen dürften für
Kunden also mancher Orts noch länger
gewesen sein und wie sieht es am Ende
dieser Woche am deutschen Aktienmarkt
aus recht gut es sieht vorläufig nämlich
nach einem Lichtblick aus denn in den
vergangenen vier Wochen hat der
daxrunden 9% draufpacken können heute
lag er zeitweilig knapp unter dem
höchsten Stand seit Ende August das
Börsenbarometer verabschiedet sich mit
einem Stand von rund
163 Punkten ins Wochenende nach dem
Black Friday ursprünglich kommt dieser
Begriff übrigens eben aus den USA und
seinen Namen könnte er einerseits von
den schwarzen Zahlen haben die der
Handel an diesem Tag üblicherweise
schreibt oder aber auch vom großen börs
Crash im Jahr
1929 als Menschenmassen panikartig ihre
Ersparnisse von den Banken
abzogen me vielen Dank ein Ergebnis aus
der Fußballbundesliga vom Abend der
erste fC Köln hatte Bayern München zu
Gast die Bayern haben 1:0
gewonnen und die deutsche U17
Fußballnationalmannschaft steht bei der
WM in Indonesien im Halbfinale durch ein
1:0 gegen
Spanien total öpft aber überglücklich
mit leidenschaftlichem Einsatz ziehen
Deutschland 17jährige ins WM Halbfinale
ein Spanien in der ersten Hälfte mit
mehr Ballbesitz und besseren Chancen
doch die deutschen werfen sich
erfolgreich in jeden Ball auf diesen
Kampfgeist setzt ihr Trainer auch in der
Pause wenn wir hinten zu Null spielen
und weiter so aufopferungsvoll kämpfen
das was die Deutschen ausmacht dann wer
das Spiel gewinnen und genuso ist es
gekommen seine nun besser Spiel
kommenden jung in der mit der
vorentscheidenden Aktion faul an Paris
Brunner klarer Strafstoß der Dortmunder
verwandelt selbst zum 1:0 eine Führung
die die deutschen bis zum Abfiff
verteidigen beim auftaktwettbewerb der
Nordischen Kombinierer kam Johannes
rüzeek hinter drei Norwegern auf Platz 4
nach dem Springen lag rützek zunächst
auf Rang 12 in der leupe holte er dann
Platz um Platz auf verpasste aber einen
der
protestplätze die gingen an die
Magnus Rieber und Jörgen
Grab das war im heute journal und es
geht direkt weiter mit Matthias fornhof
und dem ZF
Politbarometer guten Abend willkommen
zum Politbarometer es wäre zu schön
gewesen Geld aus coronakrediten einfach
für Klimaprojekte nutzen da wo es eben
gebraucht wird es geht um 60 Milliarden
Euro eine Zahl mit 10
Nullen diese Rechnung hat die
Bundesregierung aber ohne die Richter am
Verfassungsgericht gemacht Kredite mal
eben umwandeln das geht nicht jetzt also
ein Milliardenloch im Haushalt die
Mehrheit meint das fehlende Geld muss
jetzt über Ausgabenkürzungen wieder
reingeholt werden
57% sehen das so 11% sind für höhere
Steuern 23 pro finden der Bund muss
jetzt neue Schulden
machen die meisten Befragten wollen an
der Schuldenbremse festhalten die
Bundesregierung aber will sie für das
laufende Jahr aussetzen mit der
Begründung es herrsche eine
außergewöhnliche Notlage gespart werden
muss trotzdem so will die FDP beim
Sozialstaat den Rotstift ansetzen
21% glauben dass sie das auch
durchsetzen kann die große Mehrheit aber
73% bezweifelt das dass die Grünen
Kürzungen beim Klimaschutz weitgehend
vermeiden können glaubt rund einel
27%.
68% glauben das
nicht die Ampel steht mit dem Rücken zur
Wand sie muss jetzt liefern auch weil
sie ohnehin seit Monaten im Umfragetief
steckt die Weller sind weiter deutlich
unzufrieden mit ihrer
Regierung 35% finden die Ampelkoalition
macht ihre Arbeit eher gut dagegen
attestieren 60% ihr schlechte Arbeit
trotzdem wird die Regierung wohl bis zum
Ende der Legislaturperiode halten das
erwarten
64%
31% glauben dass sie noch vor der
Bundestagswahl 2025
zerbricht eine neueewahl kann sich
derzeit keine der regierenden Parteien
wünschen denn wenn am nächsten Sonntag
wirklich Bundes swahl wäre Kämme die SPD
nur noch auf
15%-1 die Union wäre weiter stärkste
Kraft 31% +1 die Grünen 15 FDP 5 beide
unverändert die AFD mit neuem Rekordwert
jetzt 22% + 1 Die Linke würde es nicht
in den Bundestag schaffen 4%
unverändert demnach hätte die Ampel
weiter keine Parlament is Mehrheit
reichen würde es unter den politisch
denkbaren Bündnissen für schwarzrot oder
schwarzgrün wobei zurzeit kein
Koalitionsmodell von den Befragten
mehrheitlich unterstützt
würde schauen wir auf unsere Top 10 also
die Bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker nach
Sympathie und Leistung auf der Skala von
+5 bis -5 bleibt alies Weidel
Schlusslicht -2,6 unverändert davor Sara
Wagen knnecht - 1,3 etwas besser als
zuletzt Christian Lindner
-0,5 wieder verschlechtert Friedrich
Merz -0,4 schlechter Olaf Scholz - 0,4
auch schlechter sein persönlicher
Negativrekord Karl Lauterbach ebenfalls
-0,4 verschlechtert Robert habck -0,3
auch verschlechtert
an win leicht dazu jetzt -
0,2 Markus Söder unverändert 0,1 und
Spitzenreiter bleibt Boris Pistorius
etwas besser als zuletzt
1,8 zuletzt war der
Verteidigungsminister in Kiev dort hat
er weitere Unterstützung zugesagt die
Ukraine hofft derweil auf ein Zeichen
aus Brüssel und auf baldige Gespräche
zum
EU-Beitritt dass die Ukraine in den
nächsten Jahren EU Mitglied wird
befürworten
52% 40% wollen das
nicht und wir schauen noch in den Nahen
Osten auf den Krieg zwischen Israel und
der Hamas in dieser Woche wurde eine
Vereinbarung getroffen zur Befreiung von
Geiseln seit heute morgen gilt eine
Waffenruhe das militärische Vorgehen
Israels im Gazastreifen findet jeder
zweite gerechtfertigt 50% ein Drittel
33% findet das
nicht dass die Hamas so geschwächt
werden kann dass sie künftig für Israel
nicht mehr gefährlich wird bezweifeln
die
meisten die schlechten Nachrichten
überwiegen leider dazu trübt der Blick
aus dem Fenster wohl zusätzlich die
Stimmung ein Lichtblick im tristen
November könnte da nicht schaden das war
unser Bericht über die Stimmung im Land
die Grafiken und alle inform zu unseren
Umfragen finden Sie wie immer im ZDF
Text ab Seite 165 in unserer ZDF heute
App und auf
zdfheute.de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
zustande kommen Informationen zur
Methodik und zu den
Qualitätsstandards finden Sie unter
politbarometer.zdf.de vielen Dank für
Ihr Interesse das nächste Politbarometer
gibt's dann am 15 Dezember hier folgt
jetzt das Wetter und dann die heutehow
einen schönen Abend auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend ich hoffe die
Winterreifen sind aufgezogen denn der
Winter nimmt jetzt an Fahrt auf die
Kombination zwischen diesem Tief und
diesem Hoch hier sorgt für sie haben
vielleicht den Begriff schon mal gehört
eine kaltluftrutsche für die arktische
Kaltluft aus Norden und da rutschen auch
zwei randtiefs mit das eine hat uns
heute Schnee und Regenschauer g das ande
bringt uns die Morgen und so liegen
morgen Abend in den Alpen stellenweise
über 30 cm Neuschnee auch im Nordstau
der restlichen Mittelgebirge sind es 5
bis 15 cm bei um 300 m liegt die
Schneefallgrenze morgen aber heute Nacht
und in Schauern können die Flocken auch
bis ganz nach unten fallen und dann wird
stellenweise glatt es ist nämlich oft
frostig heute Nacht + 4° gibt's an der
Nordsee -4° an den Alpen wichtiges Thema
heute Abend noch der Wind schwere
sturmböhen sind in Verbindung mit
Gewittern an der Nordsee und auf dem
Berg lagen auch möglich das lässt heute
Nacht aber nach und dann ziehen die
Schnee und Regenschauer vom Tag sich in
den Süden zurück an den Alpen Schneid es
sich ein von Norden wird es Trockner und
erst am Morgen kommen dann neue Schnee
und Regenfälle aus Nordwesten auf die
ziehen dann morgen über Tag rasch in den
Süden verstärken sich hier noch mal und
das ist dann meist Schneefall im Norden
da lockert es aber schnell auf wir haben
nur noch vereinzelt Schnee und
Regenschauer und an der Nordsee sind
sogar einige Stunden Sonne möglich so
ist es dann hier am mildesten mit 9° an
den Alpen bleibt es bei -1° ja und die
Aussichten zeigen uns der Winter ist
wohl erstmal gekommen um zu bleiben es
wird noch kälter am Dienstag gibt es nur
noch -3 bis + 3° und eine neue Ladung
neu Schnee das war es von uns
tschüss